the mission of eggs comp analytics is to
provide a competencies based analytics
platform for education and training we
brought a set of patents based on the
design of the system for competency
assessment and then we built set of
prototypes and hired several software
companies to come out and do individual
pieces of it when we got IBM involved
they pointed out first that we were
throwing away data that was absolutely
usable and not only that was going to be
very important in trying to build
analytics for predictor analysis I
didn't know what the term garage meant
at first the first interactions we had
is some people from Apple Computer
actually introduced us to IBM and said
Todd you need to talk to these people
because they know analytics better than
anybody and it evolved to hey y'all need
to go to a garage they brought in a set
of experts that were able to essentially
point out where we had scale issues also
they took advantage of the cloud what
IBM brought to the table was
micro-services the ability for Watson to
be plugged ended into very specific
areas to solve the specific problems and
also they simplified things I was trying
to solve this problem and we did solve
that problem with the IBM version of X
comp analytics but we also got I don't
know six new products six new analytics
environments because of looking at the
data through a garage a little bit
differently the garage helped me give
context to the projects that we were
doing there's no question that what it
does for you as it makes you rethink
things that you didn't have before
you